I live and die by the bird test when one
partner says oh that's a beautiful bird
outside does the other partner respond
with something like wow that is
beautiful or do they blow their partner
off and ignore the bird if you tell your
boyfriend or husband that there's a bird
outside and uh they go and they want to
go look at the bird then that means that
they are then they pass the test because
they they're they are taking an interest
in the thing that you are interested in
a few problems with this first of all I
would fail the bird test in a second and
I've been married for 12 years so very
you know very successfully married I
would fail the bird test um if I'm if
I'm like in the other room and my wife
yells hey come here look at this bird
I'm going to say can you take a picture
or something and send it to me why am I
getting out of my chair to go look at a
bird